What do you think about Sabo and what has
happened to him?
What if I told you that he is bringing Vivi
and the Revolutionaries to Luffy right this
moment?
That he will be more important to the story
than Ace.
And that I've actually shed a tear while writing
this script?
Actually on second thought, don't answer that.
Okay, real talk for a second.
As you know, the reason I love One Piece so
much is not because of the fights or the powers
or even the world building.
All of these are absolutely fantastic, no
question about it.
But to me, what puts One Piece above other
great works of fiction is its out-of-this-world
character writing.
Not only does the story have one of the biggest
cast of characters ever, but pretty much every
single one of them has their own personality,
development and purpose in the story.
Everyone feels like they belong into this
world and each and every one of them does
their part to make One Piece the epic adventure
it is.
Which brings me back to Sabo.
I have wanted to talk about Sabo for a while
now, because in a weird way he seems to be
the odd one out here, not just for me, but
for many others as well.
The amnesia plot-line was not very well received,
I mean you can't tell me Sabo never saw an
image of Ace in the newspaper before, and
in many ways, Sabo's only role can easily
be mistaken as a replacement for Ace.
And objectively speaking, at this point in
the story, if nothing else happened with him,
I would go so far as to call him the only
bad character in the story, because he doesn't
really contribute to Luffy's story.
However, and this is where this video turns
positive, I finally realised that by thinking
this way I might not only have judged Sabo's
role in the story extremely prematurely, but
even worse, I probably have actually drastically
underestimated the potential Sabo has for
Luffy and the endgame of the story.
Hi, my name is Manu and as an older brother
myself, I think I have finally figured out
what Sabo's character is all about, what has
happened to him during the Reverie and what
role he has to play at the end of the story.
Despite being one of the most influential
people in Luffy's life, I was surprised how
late in the story Sabo was introduced.
The first time we learn about his existence
is during Luffy's flashback after the end
of Marineford.
I
have seen a lot of people speculate that Oda
just wrote Sabo into the story at that point
on a whim, but I'm convinced that Sabo was
part of Oda's plans right from the start,
which is also why I'm not worried about him
being a character without purpose.
Here is some of the early foreshadowing by
Oda.
His first possible appearance might have been
in chapter 99, where we see someone looking
suspicipously like sabo in the crowd as Buggy
plans to execute Luffy.
This would make further sense, because it
is also Dragon's first appearance in the story.
Next we have the flashback of Luffy and Ace
sharing Sake to become brothers, and as you
can see in the top left corner, there is a
third cup, just barely visible.
Another hint, that hit me really hard when
I realised what it meant, was Ace's Tatoo,
that we first get to see in Alabasta.
At first glance it looks like he found himself
the worlds worst tattoo artist, that managed
to misspell ace with an s.
But then, we saw Sabo set out to sea [sabo
and his Jolly Roger leaving goa].
It's not a strike through S, ace has literally
tattooed Sabo's Jolly Roger on his arm as
a tribute, from the last time he saw his brother,
before seeing him die at the hands of the
celestial dragons.
Gotta be real, I teared up there a little
when I learned that.
So, I hope you agree that most likely Sabo
was always part of Oda's plan.
What then is his purpose in the story?
Is merely being a replacement for Ace?
And the answer to that is nyaaaa-kind of but
not really, but definitely in a good way.
Okay so: Sabo actually has three important
roles in the story.
For the first of these we have to go back
all the way to Luffy's childhood.
Sabo shaped both Luffy and Ace into the great
pirates that they later would become.
Ace, suffering under his heritage, was always
in a very dark place.
It was only thanks to sabo, that he was able
to find someone he could truly trust and forget
his worries with.
On top of this, Sabo served as the relaxed
and positive moderator between him and Luffy,
as both were very head-strong and impulsive.
In my opinion, Sabo might well be part of
the reason Luffy is so incredibly tolerant
toward everyone.
Even though they were living in poverty in
the shadow of the nobles, Sabo, who was a
noble himself, was just a friend and brother
to Luffy.
It taught him that a person is made by their
actions and not their heritage.
Even better, since Sabo was well-educated,
he most likely contributed most of the knowledge
that Luffy and Ace got as children.
But most importantly, Sabo was one of the
key factors, that inspired both Ace and Luffy
to become great pirates.
Shanks was definitely a major driver for luffy
as well.
However I feel like it is this scene here,
when Luffy learns about Sabo's death for the
first time, where a lot of Luffy's ideals
and even his dream can be traced back to.
[do you think sabo was happy / luffy saying
: he really wasn't happy]
Luffy realising that sabo tried to become
a pirate in order to find happiness is basically
the premise for each and every one of his
crew mates.
He finds great people that just like Sabo
have been in an incredibly dark spot their
entire life, and gives them true freedom and
happiness by making them pirates of his crew.
Luffy goes out of his way to pull people out
of their darkness, because of Sabo's death
and how he and Ace did not realize it, did
not try to help him escape his terrible family.
This of course is also connected to Ace's
death, where Luffy now feels like he had failed
to save not only one, but two brothers.
And it's exactly that subtext, that makes
Luffy's reunion with Sabo so special.
Now the only arc, where Sabo had a chance
to showcase his current personality so far,
is Dressrosa.
A big criticism I often hear is that Sabo
is basically just ace 2.0.
And in a way, these people have a point.
Both of them have similar 'cool older brother
vibes', both are powerful members of two of
the most influentail groups in the story and
both go out of their way to make sure Luffy
can go his way.
Heck, Sabo actually eats Ace's devil fruit
and uses his moves.[]
However if you have taken away anything form
the many analysis videos I have made about
One Piece, you will know that Sabo unites
two important themes Oda uses.
Inherited will as well as the concept of two
sides of the same coin, where most elements
of post-time-skip one piece are a mirrored
and inverted version of pre-time skip.
It's no coincidence then that Sabo appears
in Dressrosa, the arc that reflects Alabasta
in the first half of the grand line, where
Ace made his first appearance.
Both arcs serve as setup for Luffy's relationship
with his older brothers.
That way, Oda could set up Ace's capture at
Maarineford, and whatever happened to Sabo
at the reverie,
I'll get into that in a moment.
But to me, saying that these two characters
are the same is just not true.
Both have their distinct personalities and
differences.
And even strength-wise, Sabo seems a lot more
capable than ace.
He wields the Mera mera no mi easily right
after eating it, is able to face off with
an admiral and in this scene right here, I'm
pretty sure he uses Ryouu to split the platform.[]
A real beast.
Both have their distinct emotional baggage.
While Ace feels unwanted and hated by the
world, Sabo blames himself for not being there
for Ace and Luffy when they needed him the
most.
[sabo crushes marines mask]In his fight against
the marines he seems to go a little bit Psycho
for a while, until you realize that he is
just very emotional and trying to protect
Luffy, no matter what.
That or he is justvery ecstatic about having
subscribed to this channel for more one piece
content every single week.
Interestingly enough, Sabo becomes a little
bit more like Ace when eating the Mera Mega
no mi, even sharing the same lines as Ace.
[sabo saying goodbye and zoro remembering
ace].
This could simply be a representation of Sabo
inheriting Ace's will to watch over Luffy.
But as I speculate in my video on Devil Fruits
here, it might very well be that devil fruits
themselves store a bit of their previous owners
personality in them.
What really stands out to me though, is the
moment Luffy realizes Sabo is alive and all
Sabo tries to do is lessen Luffy's own burden
for not having saved Ace.
[] He actually thanks Luffy for being alive
like 3 or four times, making sure that Luffy
doesn't have any more survivors guilt about
Marine Ford.
And speaking of Marine Ford, there is one
really interesting detail, thatI think you
will like.
You know that Akainu's real name is actually
Sakazuki.
But what you might not know is, that Sakazuki
has an actual meaning in Japanese.
The reason his true name is so jarring is
that "Sakazuki" is the Japanese word for a
pact of brotherhood over sake cups, which
is EXACTLY what Ace, Sabo, and Monkey D. Luffy
did to signify their brotherly bond.
[]
Why would Oda choose that name?
Well when you think about it for a second,
it really fits.
While Akainu DOES kill ace and take one sake
cup brother away from Luffy, Ace's death cures
Sabo's Amnesia, giving the other sake cup
brother back to him and passes his will on
to Sabo.
Sabo even states that he felt Ace's spirit
lift the fog in his mind as a way of guaranteeing
that Luffy always had at least one brother
looking out for him.
And it might foreshadow Akainu being involved
with Sabo at some point in the story as well.
So, up until this point, I believe that Sabo
has already contributed a lot to Luffy and
to the story overall.
But I personally think that the most important
part of his arc is yet to come.
And that brings us into the realm of speculation
about what happened at Marijoe to Sabo.
[] One possibility is of course that Sabo
has been killed.
That would fit in with a theory I made about
Coby inheriting the Mera Mera no mi, but even
if Sabo were to die, it surely wouldn't be
off-screen.
Another, much more likely possibility, is
that Sabo has been captured and is about to
be executed.
While this would be a little bit too similar
to Ace's fate, it WOULD give Luffy the chance
to actually save a brother from the government
this time, which I don't hate.
However I personally think that Oda is trying
to trick us into believing one or the other.
My personal favorite idea, is that the Government
has taken out the king of alabasta, Cobra
and also tried to get rid of Vivi in the process.
This is supported by Imu picking her image
during the reverie.
I think it would be quite likely that sabo
would have gone out of his way, just as he
saved Rebecca on Dressrosa and running away
with her.
As a result, the government could have blamed
Cobra's death on Sabo, but would still want
to keep the news from spreading that a revolutionary
was able to infiltrate and escape Marijo without
being caught.
Remember this scene?
[] Sabo has a vivre card of Luffy and Vivi
is bound to return to the crew.
So if both of them escaped together from Marijoe
and Sabo can sense Luffy's vivre card burning
up during his fight with on Wano, it would
make sense for the pair to make their way
towards the straw hats, maybe bringing the
rest of the revolutionary army along to battle
the marines coming to Wano as well.
Sabo reuniting with Luffy would have an additional
meaning as well.
Remember how all his attacks are dragon based?
Well, Sabo is literally the right hand of
Dragon himself.
And we know that Luffy has no relationship
with his father at all.
However, Sabo was raised by dragon instead
and he grew up with Luffy.
So who better to bring these two together
than Luffy's older brother.
And one other thing I would really love to
see, is Sabo and Luffy visiting Ace's grave
together at the end of the story.
Or, if Luffy doesn't make it, Sabo visiting
both of their graves next to each other.
I don't know why, but I just thinking about
that scene at the end of one piece, already
puts tears in my eyes.
If you don't want to cry now, and rather learn
why devil fruits may have a will of their
own and why Sabo might have inherited Ace's
will by eating his devil fruit, just click
right on my face.
I swear my eyes are just sweating.